la parole est à monsieur michel voisin
oui merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur le ministre il y a
vingt ans à peu près le 11 juillet 1995
les forces serbes sous la conduite du
général mladic
entrez dans la case serbe de c.bruni cha
on connaît la suite
huit mille hommes âgés de 15 à 65 ans
qui pouvait porter les armes exterminer
le crime le plus odieux de guerre depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale notre groupe
d'amitié france serbie rentrer d'une
mission à belgrade auprès de nos
homologues serbes dans le même temps que
se dérouler cbre et nietzsche à des
communautés serbe était aussi exterminer
les connaissez la barbarie aujourd'hui
la grande bretagne a déposé auprès du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies un
projet de résolution qui doit être
discuté le 6 juillet prochain
concernant l'appellation de génocide
dans la sphère de cbre et nietzsche
heures monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères
la représentation nationale aimerait
connaître la position la diplomatie
française le 6 juillet prochain au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
merci la parole est à monsieur harlem
désir secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député michel voisin
il y a vingt ans comme vous venez de le
rappeler le 11 juillet 1995 plus de 8300
musulmans adultes enfants étaient
massacrés
srebrenica ces événements marquèrent les
heures les plus terribles de la guerre
de bosnie et il reste à ce jour la pire
tuerie en europe depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
la bosnie herzégovine a proposé en effet
que le conseil de sécurité adopte début
juillet une résolution pour commémorer
les 20 ans du génocide de srebrenica un
projet est donc actuellement en
discussions à new york
je rappelle que comme dans le cas du
rwanda le massacre de srebrenica a été
qualifié de génocide par des
juridictions internationales
la france souhaite donc que cette
résolution le fasse mais qu'elles
permettent non seulement de faire oeuvre
de mémoire mais qu'elle contribue
également au rapprochement des états de
la région autour d'un avenir européen
partagé
c'est en ce sens que nous y travaillons
dans les balkans des progrès
incontestables ont été réalisés au cours
des dernières années je pense par
exemple aux relations entre la serbie et
le kosovo et tous les pays des balkans
sont aujourd'hui engagés dans un
rapprochement avec l'union européenne
vous étiez à belgrade
et vous savez la démarche qui est celle
aujourd'hui du gouvernement serbe et de
l'ensemble de la société serbe pour
faire aboutir cette procédure d'adhésion
à l'union européenne et donc de partage
des valeurs de paix de l'union
européenne et la récite la situation
reste malgré tout fragile
tous les états doivent continuer leurs
efforts pour contribuer à la stabilité
et ne pas répéter les erreurs du passé
les événements récents en macédoine
montre l'importance que tous les acteurs
politiques soient bien dans cet état
d'esprit le 11 juillet prochain
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale se réunira donc en bosnie
herzégovine à srebrenica pour rendre
hommage aux victimes de ce massacre et à
l'ensemble des personnes qui ont
souffert de la guerre et pour permettre
que la halle et la région des balkans se
projette dans cet avenir européen
je vends mes nerfs